first off what what happened out here
tonight well you want to go over and I
show you where happened by my tractor
well I just need to know what happened
what happened well I was unless there's
some kind of evidence
there marks on the ground maybe he's
okay and I lost my hat there anyway I
just my chainsaw off cuz it's getting
dark okay I cutting TR a little firewood
okay and I didn't hear him come up to me
but he grabbed me by his left shoulder
swung me around his first hit I think
was here and then I went down on the
ground and I crawl under the little bit
under the back of my tractor to keep him
from hitting me much more cuz he wasn't
hitting me in the body he was just
trying to hit me in the head and in the
shoulders okay and he kept pulling me
out and he said he's going to kill
me and he said he was going to kill my
daughter and the grandkids they live in
Chico carg but they come here quite
often okay and uh he hit me about 30
times
okay did he hit you was it just with a
fist or was it a stick or anything else
just his fist just his fist okay he
didn't even know enough to double it up
hard is is there a a history of Bad
Blood between you two or yes okay but I
haven't even spoke to him in probably 3
4 years okay where does he live at from
here very next house right next door
okay okay so you are on your property oh
yeah okay how much property do do you
have back here I got 20 acres 20 acres
okay so you drove your tractor back
there and I'm just going back over this
and then you got a good picture let me
pull the car over here and then she be
any minute so you were cut for about 45
minutes you'd shut your chainsaw off I
just shut it
off virally a second before he grabbed
my shoulder and spun me around okay so
you were facing away you never seen him
coming no never seen he just grabbed you
by your left shoulder yeah and then spun
you around yeah and
said I'm going to kill you okay he said
he's going to kill you as he was hitting
me he said I'm going to kill you and I'm
going to kill your daughter and I'm
going to kill your grandkids okay he
says I just found out I got prostate
cancer and I'm going to
die okay so but so he said that that
stuff and then started punching you well
he was already punching me then okay he
said he's punching and then he said that
at least once maybe twice more okay so
when he first grabbed you and spun you
around at that point did he say I'm
going to kill you and then started
punching you
well I could I guess I really can't say
for sure which was first was all about
the same time yep okay but there was no
but there was no other conversation no
just grabbed you turned around and just
started beating on you and hit you
approximately 25 to 30 times yeah okay
and during that time during while he was
hitting you is what you're saying that
he was saying he was going to kill you
and hurt your family and stuff kill me
kill my daughter and kill he that's the
words he used kill yep yep so what
happened after he stopped did he stay
there or did he just take off he just
let let go of me stood up and walked
away walked back in his yard
okay hi hi
Greg
wait sorry how you doing sir um okay
angry come in all right want you we'll
just stay out here and talk for a second
oh um I have a small dog he's right here
oh jeez you want to put him back in
first yes all right yeah what's your
name I'm Deputy Weekley van bar County
Sheriff's Office what's your first name
Gabe Gabe
okay
Bravo
I already know why you're here but you
want to come in no I just I'll stand
outside and talk with you you want to
put your dog in so yeah
okay all right Greg so you say you know
why I'm already here mhm so what started
this
tonight good
question uh Neighbors always making
noise over next to my house I'm tired of
it we don't get
along okay it's been going on for well
since I moved in here okay and it's not
going to go
away I'm
hoping in my heart that I outlive
him
okay but as far as tonight what
what what made you go over there
and I would
say
he's always doing things to annoy me
which which which will go on forever I
mean I moved in here he was already here
him and his wife we've
had property line dispute
and he he just likes to
be right up in my
business I feel like you know to me so
if I was going to tell a judge if I have
to go in front of a
judge he has 18 Acres he's always right
in my face that's why I put up a fence
and he's right there and
uh so right tonight right there so
tonight can you explain to me the events
that exactly I mean I've already got his
side of the story too yeah so just just
tell me what happened that's what I'm
looking for all right so you were in the
house start out here you were in the
house chainsaw running over there right
next to my house I don't know where you
live how you live right next to my house
you know the guy's got 188 I think he
likes to annoy me and I would tell a
judge to this okay but but the events
the events tonight let's stay on that
path oh okay
um it was right there
just in the middle of the
night just before dark running his
chainsaw and
um it's I take it
personally because the man has 18 Acres
he could he could chop all kinds of tre
stop he um he does not like me we hate
each other we hate each other we're
veering off the path of tonight though
okay okay um we hate each other and I
punched him in the face okay so did you
talk did you talk to him at first did
you guys have a conversation or did you
just go over grab a hold of him turn him
around and start beating on no no um no
we do not speak okay we do not so you
didn't you didn't speak at all you just
walked up grabbed him um no we do speak
but this has been going on for 20 years
he's he's I hate him he hates me okay
that's why there's a fence there okay
but I'm talking now we're veering off
that path again I lost my
temp okay and I went and and I went and
yeah I'm tired of it and I told them
okay so I'm retired okay I have no
children he has kids he has grandkids I
told him I know you see this on TV all
the time I will take
down okay okay what okay okay so you're
saying okay like stop doing this you got
18 Acres mother you're doing this so
he's
aggravating agitating me I know you know
how this goes you probably it's a
property
dispute when I go I have prostate cancer
when I go
guess who's going to go with
me guess who's going to go with me I'm
going to die of cancer anyway okay I'm
just putting my rubber band on so I'm
not trying to put words in your mouth
but is that where some of this is coming
from tonight so you've got the prostate
cancer and you figured I'm going to go
over and put an end to this tonight and
you went over there not yet not yet I I
would like him to stop okay I if you
talk to him if you go there what's your
name again Deputy weekly weekly okay if
you go talk to him
again I would like him to stay away from
me okay if he does not stay away from me
we're both going to go up there okay are
so are you threatening
him um I can't really I mean I don't
know how I do so here's the deal so like
this line right here okay he owns this
you own this right up to the right up
like as tight as water right yes so he
has he pays taxes on this right and you
pay taxes on this right yes so he has he
can come right up and cut every blade of
grass right up to your right up to your
line he can make as much noise he can do
whatever there's no noise ordinance
there's nothing he can do whatever he
wants on his property okay can I so yeah
you can too as long as you're on your
property can I put up a stereo and and
play r
music Bo just drive him nuts if you want
to be one of those guys I and then deal
with it you know but that's how I feel
Deputy that's how I feel like um could I
put up a fan could I start a bonfire the
thing is is you already put up a fence
okay yes you put up a fence he was on
his side of the fence tonight right yes
and you walked around your fence yes and
you walked up and you grabbed grabed him
by the shoulder turned him around mhm
and you you started smoking him right
how how many times did you hit him 25 30
times maybe no probably five or six like
you're not even supposed to hit your
neighbor once okay okay look I hate the
guy I want him to die
okay so were you I'm trying to was your
attempt was your attempt tonight to kill
him no I just want him to stop he I know
he screwing with me okay which I know
you can't legally you can screw so I'm
going to pull up my car tomorrow let's
say tomorrow and I'm going to blast out
some rap music as loud as I can with my
speakers okay and I'm just going to
blast it at his house he probably would
not like
that we basically hate each other he
wants me to die I know he does I want
him to die
um but I can't do I
asally how can I here we've W you can't
other than outlive him you can't okay I
hate that man so here's the deal so what
you're telling me is tonight you were in
the house he's over there cutting wood
you got irritated yes you walked over
there you grabbed a hole of him and you
you punched him multiple times yes was
he fighting back or was he trying to get
away from you he was trying to get away
from me okay you have to say everything
legal I understand no I'm just I'm
trying to get us what I actually haveen
that's what that's what I'm here for
okay well it's your job yep I get it
okay so Greg at this point right now
what I'm going to do is I want you to
turn around put your hands behind your
back for me I want you interlace your
fingers interlace your fingers like
you're praying I will no interlace your
fingers like you're praying oh well will
um you like the
door just a
second keep your hand right
[Music]
there with
you I'm more worried about the dog okay
where's your wife at she's that Cedar
Point that Cedar Point yeah she's that
Cedar Point all right Greg how much have
you had to drink tonight uh let see
enough how much how much would you say
is
enough five six shot five or six shot
but I know you guys double it so no we
don't double nothing it is what it is oh
the doctor does all right I'm going to
I'm going to pain you down GRE okay you
have any knives on you mm nothing on you
nope no no guns no explosives no nothing
what's your first name again Gabe
Weekley okay okay all right this is your
wallet with your I think I've seen you
before
um jeez I get the Popa paper
and what's a would you would you at
least lock the back door what are
these oh Mints not
drugs can I have
one okay you're doing your
job
oh my wife's going to be so
mad could you will you Gabe lock the
back door yep I'll lock it for okay on
the inside you just lock it oh she's
going to be
so anyway she might not
know
okay all right walk back here with me
mhm walk back here to my car then I'll
come back here and lock up your thank
your door okay oh God this is
so anyway so do you ever see stuff about
property
disputes because I talked to a counselor
and they asked
me I'm sorry keep
walking I think sometimes I think if I
take him with me what's that I have
prostate cancer do you yeah if I take
him him yeah who's what are you going to
do what why are you going to take him oh
cuz I'm going to die anyway okay yeah
and so take him yeah that's what I
wanted him to know okay yeah yeah and
actually after you let me go a little
bit further right there if you let me go
now I'm really
mad okay um so I I might just go ahead
and take him okay okay oh jeez okay go
ahead and put your butt in there and
swing your feet in that's easiest way to
do it are you allowed
to okay your but you're just doing your
chat ow ow you're just doing your job
anyway next time I see you I'll probably
be in a coffin and so will
he which I'm planning on will you lock
the back door please yes I told you I'm
going to go back lock lock the door okay
thank you I appreciate
it I care more about the dog than I do
myself do you understand each of these
rights I have explained to you yes I do
okay y having these rights in mind do
you wish to talk to me
now sure you had the stuff on sorry I'm
not being sarcastic hey you had this
stuff on your Keys the stuff can't go in
the jail do you want me to just throw it
away uhuh
oh I'm not taking it it can't come in
the jail
oh okay that's up to you I trust you all
right